this is a production of cornell
university
i'm larry smart i'm a professor in the
horticulture section of the school of
integrated plant science
based here at cornell agritech in geneva
so at cornell we started hemp research
in late 2016.
we have been doing
variety evaluations
assessment of disease threats and insect
pest threats
and
doing some work on crop management
especially
disease management and weed management
so with legalization of hemp in the 2014
farm bill
cornell
eagerly took up the challenge of
starting to work on this crop
that has not been studied for decades
and has a high regulatory burden uh for
us as researchers we've been very
fortunate at cornell to have active
engagement across multiple disciplines
to build a
engaged and diverse team of researchers
and extension specialists including
myself as a plant breeder
joss rose
doing biochemistry of cannabinoids which
is critical
to maintain compliance and to breed
compliant cultivars
chris smart and gary bergstrom in plant
pathology
evaluating disease threats
and neil matson of working on controlled
environment production
most recently lynn sosnoski here at
cornell agritech has joined our team
working on herbicide advocacy and weed
management alan taylor is our seed
scientist
studying seed quality
and working on seed coatings
we have been very fortunate to have a
strong collaboration with new york state
department of agriculture and markets
who has given us quite a bit of latitude
for
what i would call self-auditing and
self-regulation
and because of that i think we have been
able to make some major breakthroughs in
our understanding of the genetic basis
of thc and cbd production
which has contributed to
rapid breeding for thc compliance and
truly an understanding of the genetic
basis uh for
uh thc production and thc compliance in
hemp crops
we have also gotten strong support
from new york state with strong
supporters in the legislature and the
governor's office
to initiate the first land-grant
academic
hemp breeding program
so we have been breeding hemp varieties
building a hemp germ plasm collection
and developing markers for marker
assisted selection since early 2017.
our phenotyping is largely based on the
evaluation of current commercial
cultivars
in three market classes
we are very interested in developing
new cultivars for grain production
and the grain will meet
a niche
for
animal feed particularly organic animal
feed we see strong potential
in the poultry market for hemp grain
improving egg quality it is a
gluten-free feed so we see strong
potential for beef
and
actually pet food
production
but it also is a source of protein
and potential ingredient
source for plant-based meats
and also it produces a very healthy oil
which is also used in health and
cosmetic products
so there is a strong potential to
increase
yield of grain production
we're also very interested in the fiber
market and this field behind me
is evaluation in strip trials of some
fiber varieties from china
which flower extremely late which makes
them very good
biomass and fiber producers
we see strong potential
in fiber production
not only for the long strong bass fibers
which
can go into technical applications
reinforced panels
building materials insulation materials
for example but also for the inner herd
the inner core of the stem
which has potential again for
construction materials in the form of
hemp creek but also serves as a very
good absorbent product for animal
bedding and in fact that is one of the
immediate products that has gone
onto the market is for
small animal bedding for your gerbil
cage for example
a lot of potential for further
development of products
for example
absorbent products for diapers
for environmental cleanup
uh and other applications so once we
have sufficient agricultural production
of hemp i think we're going to see
a great market expansion and
diversification of the products that we
can make both from the grain and from
the stem
a lot of the hype around hemp has been
based on the production of cannabinoids
primarily cannabidiol or cbd
so we saw a huge
interest in 2019
from farmers
after uh
cannabis sativa was taken off of
schedule one hemp was taken off of
schedule one by the uh 2018 farm bill
that
released a lot of the regulatory issues
and encouraged farmers to take up the
production of hemp
but that resulted in extreme over
production
estimates uh that we produced as much as
four or five fold more
biomass than the market could bear and
in fact there are still growers who have
material in storage
uh that has not been fully processed
from the 2019 growing season
so prices crashed and we see this sort
of classic characteristic characteristic
roller coaster ride
of over enthusiasm over-production
and then a crash of prices
uh
a disillusionment
and now we are in the process of
diversification of the market
and uh re-engagement of growers
as we continue to improve production
practices and
uh develop new varieties to meet those
needs of the market so the farm bill
authorized us to do research on hemp
hemp and drug type cannabis are a single
same species
cannabis sativa
in fact
we
through some of our work we have
identified that there is a rather simple
genetic basis
for either high thc production
relatively equal mixed production of thc
and cbd
or high cbd production
the interesting phenomenon that we've
characterized in cbd hemp is that the
enzyme cbda synthase
also produces
a certain amount of thc
so every cbd hemp plant also makes a
little bit of thc
we at cornell only work on hemp which is
cannabis sativa that produces less than
0.3 percent percent thc
those regulations have been a patchwork
from state to state and again new york
state has been
rather
a rather compliant state to grow hemp in
because their regulations have been
based on quantification of delta 9 thc
rather than total thc
these are some of the complications and
regulatory burdens that we face
in working with hemp
we've also been very fortunate at
cornell agritech to receive strong
support from usda ars
and in fact through initiatives from
senator schumer's office
ars decided to locate
the new hemp
germplasm repository at cornell agritech
in geneva
so that will be a tremendous advantage
for us in our breeding program to be
able to work side by side with the
curator of the germplasm collection
and
geneticists characterizing that
collection
we will work with them to assemble
material
make sure that it is compliant for thc
so that it can be entered into the
repository
scaled up and then distributed to hemp
breeders
so
for every other crop
that
academic and industrial breeders work on
there is
an extensive and well characterized
germplasm collection
that
used to exist for hemp
uh was assembled back in the 1930s 20s
and 30s
but then was destroyed when hemp was put
on the controlled substance list
so right now we face the process of
reassembling
a diverse germplasm collection and
characterizing it using modern feeding
phenotyping and genotyping tools
so that there is useful
and diverse germplasm
ongoing into the future for industrial
and academic hemp breeders
so this is our fourth year of evaluating
cannabinoid hemp varieties
this trial behind me we have 40
different
cbd and now
cannabidioral cbg varieties that we
evaluate in small plots five plant plots
replicated four times in the field
we're using typical production
practices
for the northeast which is
to plant into raised beds with plastic
mulch for weed management
we put down landscape fabric in the
alleys
so that we don't have to mow and also to
provide a nice uniform background for
drone imaging
so we will be doing active weekly drone
imaging of this trial
to
be able to quantify
nutrient status
any disease and pest incidents
initiation of flowering
and to use lidar to estimate biomass
production and yield
by evaluating these cultivars for the
last four years actually we have
identified trait segregation
because the state of hemp breeding is
still in its infancy for cbd production
in the u.s
so actually many of the quote-unquote
cultivars that we have evaluated have
been segregating some of them
segregating dramatically for
single major gene traits
such as flowering time
so we have been able to
map and identify candidate genes
that determine
day neutrality
hemp is a short day plant
but does have some variants that are day
neutral that will flower after a certain
maturity date
so that is a simple
single gene recessive trait
that is segregating
three to one in f2 populations
we are also very interested in mapping
genes for powdery mildew resistance
powdery mildew is
one of the diseases that has been uh
most
abundant most uh prevalent in the
northeast and in new york it's also an
important
pathogen in controlled environment
production
so if we can identify
genes and molecular markers to
introgress powdery mildew resistance it
would have a big impact on the industry
we by evaluating cultivars year after
year with chris smart
and her lab doing
the powdery mildew evaluations and
characterizing powdery mildew
populations
we have been able to identify some
varieties that show consistent strong
resistance
and have developed f2 mapping
populations which we have in the field
this year
hopefully to identify
genes for either susceptibility or
resistance to powdery mildew
we will also be
sequencing the goal of enemies genome
once we can get sufficient high quality
dna
so in addition to mapping major genes
for powder humidity resistance and for
the day neutral trait we are very
interested in quantifying the
quantitative differences in
critical day length
so there is quite a bit of variation in
flowering time from
late july early august through
early october
which will be represents adaptation to
different latitudes
and
being able to develop cultivars
with the proper
critical day length and flowering time
sensitivity for different latitudes is a
big issue right now
for example there is a lot of interest
in the southeast and in texas
in fiber production
but most of the fiber varieties have
been developed at northerly latitudes
so they flower very early when we bring
them to southern latitudes
also
there are
tropical countries that have been
growing fibre hemp
forever
but do not have access to high cbd hemp
which have been developed
by crossing hemp with
high thc cannabis and then selecting for
high cbd production in those
effectively hybrids
so
there are folks
at equatorial latitudes that are very
interested in having high cbd hemp
which can grow on a 12-hour 12-hour
cycle
that's that's a problem that we have not
solved yet
another trait that we're very interested
in characterizing is the relationship of
cannabinoid production to
insect damage
and
it has long been theorized that
hemp produces cannabinoids thc and cbd
potentially for insect defense
we have a little bit of insight into
that because there are cannabinoid-free
grain and fiber cultivars
and we have seen
that those particular cultivars seem to
be
heavily damaged
by herbivory from japanese beetle
so this
observation has led us to test the
hypothesis that
the production of cannabinoids plays a
role
in
pest interactions perhaps as a defensive
agent or perhaps in
the deterrence of pests from herbivory
we have developed a mapping population
that has variation in cannabinoid
production
some plants are are cannabinoid
competent some are cannabinoid deficient
and we have planted those on multiple
sites and will survey for
relative damage by insect pests in the
field
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu